Hannon: Welcome.
Thank you for coming
to our session,
Google Wave: Under the Hood.
We hope you enjoyed
the demo this morning
And we're really excited
to tell you
about the technology
that makes this all possible.
We have four amazing engineers
coming up here to talk to you
starting with David Wang,
then Alex Mah,
then Dan Danilatos,
then Casey Whitelaw.
They're going to show you
those algorithms and technology
that make the real time
collaboration possible.
They're going to talk
about the extensibility
of our editor,
and--and how we built it,
and what's special about it.
And finally, you saw
our spell checker this morning.
And, um, Casey will come
and talk about,
uh, the technology
and--and what makes that
possible.
And we just really, really
appreciate you being here
and for all your interest
and excitement
about Google Wave.
I just want to remind you
before I turn it over to them
that you can give feedback
at haveasecond--
haveasec--sorry--
haveasec.com/io--
feedback about this sessions,
any of the other Wave sessions,
and we really look forward
to hearing from you.
So here's David.
Wang: Thank you,
Stephanie.
All right.
So by now
you're probably thinking
what are Waves in terms
of a technology perspective?
Waves are essentially
hosted XML documents.
Um, they can be used
to represent rich text content
and system data as well.
Waves also support
live collaboration,
which you've seen
in Lars' demos.
And that means being able
to look at the same Wave
on multiple clients.
And in one client,
being able to type.
And on the other clients,
being able to see those typing
coming out
character by character
and in real time as well.
Wave is also a robust
and extendable platform
which allows you to build
extensions on top.
And I hope that you visited
the, uh, Extensions talk
previously.
Okay. So in this talk,
we'll first talk
about concurrency control,
which makes the live,
collaborative editing possible.
And then we'll talk
about the editor,
which actually allows you
to input and display
the live characters.
And at the very end
of the talk,
uh, we'll tell you
about our cool spelling agent,
um, which is enabled
by this web technology.
All right,
so let me start off
by talking
about concurrency control.
So some of you guys
who's, um, familiar
with concurrent editors,
the real--you'll realize
there's actually a number
of concurrent editors
on a--um, out there already.
There's, uh, EtherPad
and there's Subetha Edit.
They support live,
concurrent editing,
but they don't support
rich text.
There are other
rich text editors
like Google Documents.
But it doesn't really support
live and concurrent editing.
For Google Wave,
we wanted both.
And so we looked
to this technology
called Operational
Transformation.
And our starting point
was the paper called
"High-Latency,
Low-Bandwith Windowing
in the Jupiter
Collaboration System."
Two of these two--
um, two of the four authors,
uh, Mike--uh, Michael Dixon
and John Lamping,
actually worked for Google
and they've been very helpful
to us in the early establishment
of our concurrency control.
So how does Operational
Transformation work?
So let me explain it
through a very simple example.
Imagine there is
a client and server
who wants to concurrently modify
a single piece of text ABCDE.
Now imagine the client
wants to delete character four.
Uh, in this case,
um, you want to delete D.
So the client deletes
the character
and sends the operation
on the wire.
And the client
is now at a state ABCE.
Now the client sends
an operational wire
because it's much cheaper
than sending the entire document
on the wire.
Um, the server,
on the other hand,
wants to actually delete
character two.
So it goes ahead
and deletes it.
Ends up in a state A, C,
uh, D and E.
And now those two operations
cross on the wire.
If the server goes
and naively executes
the client operation
"delete character four,"
the server ends up
in a state A, C and D.
It didn't actually perform
the correct operation
at the end of the day
because it deleted
the wrong character.
Why did that happen?
That was because the server
previously executed an operation
before
"delete character four."
So how do we solve this?
This is where Operational
Transformation comes in.
In Operational Transformation,
there is a process
called, uh, transform
where you look at your,
um, received operation
and then you transform it,
uh, against operations
that you have already
applied.
So in this case,
the "delete 4"
is transformed
against "delete 2"
to recei--to become
a new operation
called "delete 3."
And now the server applies
this new operation
and it ends up
in a correct state
of A, C and E.
Now the client does the same
transformation process.
And it just happens
that the transformation
of "delete 2" against "delete 4"
for the client
is still the same operation,
"delete 2."
And magically,
both the client and the server
arrives at the same state,
ACE.
Now hopefully you realize
that it's very important
that both the client
and the server
executes the exact same
algorithm
to make this happen.
So here's
a more formal statement
about Operational
Transformation.
And it says that any changes
to the shared object
are described as operations.
So, for example,
insert character "a"
at position x.
And there must be a function
called transform()
with the following behavior
where if you're taking
a server operation, S,
and a client operation, C,
you must be able to produce
a pair of operations,
S' and C'
with the following
characteristic
that if you apply
the server operation first,
then the client operation
and the transformed
client operation,
you end up
in the same state
as if you apply
the client operation,
then the transformed
server operation.
Now this can be represented
in a two-dimensional diagram,
um, to the right
where they both start off
in the same state.
When--as the client
executes an operation,
it moves to a diff--
a-a state to the left.
And the server executes
it's own operation.
It moves the state,
uh, to the right.
And later on,
they converge again
when they apply
the transform operation.
Okay. So this a,
um, state space diagram
representation
of the previous example
where in this--
in this diagram,
you can see
that any left transversal
is caused
by client operations
and any right traversal,
um, is caused
by server operations.
And in--in this example
that you've seen previously,
the client goes
on the solid line
where it goes,
um, ABCDE,
then it goes into ABC--
uh, ABCE state,
and then finally goes
into the ACE state.
And the server follows
the, uh, state on the right.
Now this
is a very simple example.
But in a real
running system,
the, uh, state algorithm
looks a lot more complex.
But the important thing
to point out here
is you can see
that the client and the server
can diverge
more than one operation.
In fact, they can diverge
arbitrary number of operations.
And this is
an excellent property
of Operational Transformation,
which makes the client resilient
to, uh, latency
to the server.
In fact, an offline client
essentially is a client
that pretends to have very long
latency to the server.
And when it finally goes back
onto the server,
it uploads all operations
and voila,
you have a merged document.
Now we have actually made,
uh, a number of changes
to the standard
Operation Transformation
that you find in the literature
out there.
The number one change we made
to Operational Transformation
is that the client must wait
for acknowledgment
from the server
before it sends more operations
to the server.
Uh, why do we need
to do that?
The reason
we want to do that
is because
in Operational Transformation,
a client and the server
works in pairs
because their state space
is unique to the pair.
That means for every connected
client to the server,
you need to keep a state space
for the client.
Now if an end client
is collected to the server
I have to keep
end state spaces.
That's pretty expensive
to keep in the server's memory
all the time.
So by making the client wait
for the server to acknowledge,
the server
no longer have to keep
those state spaces around
because the client
can always infer
where the server is.
And that means
the client infers
the dotted line, okay?
And by doing this,
the server only has
to transform
the received operation
against it's own
operation history.
It's a very straightforward,
simple server implementation.
Another improvement we made
to Operational Transformation,
um, is that we've added
support for recovery.
And that means
a server can crash,
a client can disconnect.
But in fact, any form
of communication failure,
uh, we can recover
from that.
And this is probably,
um, one of the starting points
how we can do
offline client.
Essentially, when on offline
client goes back online,
its as though
it has disconnected
or a server's crashed,
and just recovers gracefully
from that.
Okay, now let me introduce
Alex Mah,
who will actually talk
about the operations
we've actually used
in Google Wave,
uh, in particular,
how we've w--
we made them really efficient
to working a large scale system.
[applause]
Mah: Okay. Uh...
Sorry. Sorry.
Um...
can you control this?
Okay, um...
Sorry.
Uh, w--uh, we've introduced
several, um, interesting,
uh, capabilities
to our, uh, Wave operations
to make them more powerful
and more efficient.
Um, one of the major,
um, improvements we've made--
one of the major capabilities
we've added in
is the ability for, um, a--any--
any two consecutive operations
to, uh, compose together
to form another single
operation.
Okay? What that--
what that means
is if you have an operation A
followed by an operation B,
um, then their composition
B dot A,
uh, can be expressed
as a single operation.
Um, okay, uh, um,
this--this gives us a--
there's a lot
of really interesting things
we can do
with this capability.
Um, one of them, uh, relates
to how you can use these,
uh, this capability
to speed up transformations
quite a lot.
Um, in a traditional,
uh, uh, operational transform,
uh, um, frameworks,
uh, when the client and server,
uh, get too far off sync,
then, uh, resolving,
uh, the, uh, um, their states
through concurrency control,
uh, can become quite, uh,
uh, ex--expensive.
So for example, if you have,
um, M client operations
and N server operations--
Uh, if you have M client
operations
which the server hasn't yet
had, uh, seen
and--and server operations
which the--which the client
hasn't yet seen,
uh, then in order to resolve,
uh, the concurrency control,
uh, um, uh, you need
to do NM transformations.
Okay?
So that's quite a lot.
For example, if you--if there's
a thousand server operations
and a thousand
client operations,
which, uh, need to transform
against each other,
uh, that's already
a million, uh, transformations.
So it's quite expensive.
Uh, but with, uh, ab--
uh, ability
to compose operations together,
uh, efficiently,
what you can actually do
is you can,
uh, compose together
all the client operations,
um, beforehand
and compose to all the ser--
uh, server operations beforehand
and do a single
transformation.
Um, of course, this is only
an, uh, efficiency improvement
if we can, uh, both compose,
uh, operations efficiently
and also transform the compose
operations efficiently.
Okay. Um, and we have
actually managed
to, uh, make them both
very efficient, okay?
And I'm about to explain
how we actually do that.
Um, first of all,
the document interface,
um, this is an interface
that operations apply to.
Um, I'm showing it,
uh, I'm showing it here now
because it gives you some idea
what the operations
actually look like
and how the operations
actually work.
Um, the way the operations
actually, uh, apply
to the document
is the operation stream
are linearly ordered,
uh, uh, list of modifications
into the do--
uh, document, okay?
So these are--the--
uh, these operations
look like, uh, uh, uh,
an ordered list
of--of modifications,
uh, which are linearly ordered
depending, uh, uh, relative
to their location
in the document.
Okay. And the way
we can actually use this,
uh, linear order, uh, to, um,
compose them efficiently,
uh, is by--by just zipping.
If you have two, uh,
two, uh, operations--
two consecutive operations,
um, which are in this
ordered, uh, list format,
then all it takes
to compose them together
is to linearly traverse
the two lists
and zip them together, okay?
Uh, so this,
uh, uh, effectively,
uh, com--combines
the--the effects of the two,
uh, uh, two operations
in a very--
very efficient way.
And similarly, um, when,
uh, this gives us
also a very efficient way
to do transformations
because, um, to do
transformations,
um, instead of just,
uh, traversing two--
uh, sucking in two--
two, uh, uh, linear lists,
and spitting out
a single linear list,
uh, we--we're spitting out
two linearly lists this time.
Okay? Uh, so the operation--
uh, so composition
and transformations,
uh, they work
in a--using a very similar,
um, mechanism.
They just, uh,
pull in two--
uh, traverse two--two,
uh, ordered lists
in--simultaneously,
um, and spit out
the--the result.
Okay?
Um, this gives you a--
Um, because--because the--
uh, when you're composing,
uh, the two, uh,
operations,
uh, the--the little
modifications
in the two operations
can actually overlap
and, um, interfere
with ea--each other,
uh, you can't just zip together
the modifications directly.
Uh, what you have to do
is you have to do a-a proper zip
similar to how you might
do a zip
in an, uh, uh,
a-a functional ordered--
func--sorry, a functional
programming language.
If you're used to functional
programming languages,
you might know
a lot of zip functions
are quite common.
Um, but, uh--
so what actually
happens here
is, uh, if you look at
the diagram here,
the top bar in the diagram--
diagram represents the--
the document before
the first operation is applied.
The middle horizontal bar
represents the document
after the first operation
has been applied.
And the bottom,
uh, bottom horizontal bar
represents the up--uh, document
after the second operation
has been applied.
So what the--the white
parallelograms represents,
um, just content that just
pass through by the operation.
Uh, the, uh, the orange,
uh, triangles
represents content
that has been deleted.
And the green triangles
represents content
that has been added
to the document, okay?
So if you--
um, so this is--
this is a--
uh, these horizontal bars
are just linear views
of the document.
Okay, so--so this is actually
a very greatly simplified,
uh, document view.
In actual fact,
our--our real document
is quite a bit
more complicated.
But, uh, for the purpose
of illustration,
uh, this is, uh, roughly
what the documents look like.
Um, so what we do
is we spit out these, um,
these, uh, these operations,
uh, into smaller bits,
uh, such that you
can perfectly match
every bit in the top,
uh, in the first operation
with every bit
in the second operation.
Uh, that's what's illustrated
by the b--uh, bottom diagram.
Um, and then what we do
is we pretty much glue
the top and bottom
operations together
along the middle document,
okay?
And when you,
uh, if you think of it,
uh, these, um, operations
as little rubber sheets--
uh, if you glue along
the middle line
and let the rubber sheets go,
you get something
which looks a bit
like the--the bottom,
uh, diagram.
And these, uh, this gives you
a better illustration
of which--which bits
are matched--
which bits
in the first operation
are matched with which bits
in the second operation.
So for example,
uh, the two A's, um,
they just
pass through content.
Uh, their composition
is, uh, just a single A,
which passes through
content.
Um, if content is deleted
either by the first
op--operation
or the second operation,
uh, that content
still remains deleted
in the--in their composition.
Okay. That--that content
is, uh, um, deleted
by their composition.
And if anything
is inserted
by the--the first
or second operation,
um, then, uh, that--
that content is inserted
by the composition.
Uh, now the interesting bit
is, uh, uh, the--the K,
um, since the K--
the--what the K represents
is the K represents content
that has been inserted
by the first operation,
but deleted
by the second operation.
When--when you glue
those two together, um,
they just disappear, okay?
So that's why K doesn't appear
in the bottom, um, diagram.
Okay. So that gives you a, um,
a more detail, uh, idea
of how our composition
actually works so efficiently.
Um, another--
another interesting things
you can, uh, you--you can do
with composition tree is--
Sorry.
Another interesting thing
you can do with compositions,
is to create
a composition tree.
And the way you actually create
a composition tree,
um, suppose you have
a linear sequence of operations.
Um, what you do
is you group each,
uh, these operations
into adjacent pairs,
and you compose each pair
to give you the next level
up in the tree.
So, um, all the--
all the operations
in your sequence are--
make up your--your leaf notes
of the--of your tree.
Um, you compare
each adjacent pair
to get--give you the next
level up.
And--and, uh, so on,
up the levels, okay?
Uh, for each level, you com--
just compose the, uh, operations
in the next level down,
okay?
So what that gives you
is it gives you a tree,
uh, where each node,
uh, represents the composition
of its two child nodes.
And, uh, what
you can actually do
with this data structure
is you can jump
from any point in history
to any other point in history
using only a logarithmic number
of operations.
Uh, uh, is this,
uh, working?
Okay, so, um, for example,
if you want to jump
from the point
just before operation 4
to the point just after
operation 14,
you only need to apply
four operations.
Um, this is a-a huge saving,
um, if you--if you--
if you want to de--
um, play back,
jump to any point--
if you want to play back
an operation's history,
uh, and you want to jump
to any point in that playback,
it only takes a logarithmic
number of operations
to jump to that point.
Uh, if you want to find
the difference
between any points--
uh, any two points
in the history,
um, you can just,
uh, create a logarithmic
number of operations,
which represent the ju--
represents the jump
between the two points
and compose them together
to--to give you the difference
between two points, okay?
So it's very,
uh, very efficient,
um, to jump around.
Okay, uh, that's...
uh, the--the end
of my segment.
And, uh, I'll hand you over
to Dan, our editor guy.
[applause]
Danilatos:
Uh, thanks, Alex.
Uh, hi, everyone.
I'm Dan.
So Dave and Alex
just gave you a quick overview
of how, uh, we use
concurrency control
and Operational Transform
to shuffle these operations
between clients and agents.
Um, now one of the end points,
uh, sitting on top of that,
uh, is--is the editor.
So that's a source and a sync
of these operations.
Uh, just to show you
a bit of context here,
um, you can see the editor
sitting on top of that.
So it just gets
a serial, uh, stream
of--of operations
coming in and out of it.
Um, so what kind
of properties--
what--what are the--
what are the goals
of--of an editor?
You guys saw the demo,
I suppose,
so, um, the kinds of things
that we want it
to be capable of.
So obviously we want
a high granularity
of--of extraction
and application
of outgoing and incoming
operations.
At the same time,
we want to support
rich text and media
and--and we want to make--
be able to make it extensible.
Have users ex--
have developers extend it
with their custom,
uh, widgets, gadgets,
and so forth.
And so to do this,
um, and--and to be able
to interact with--
with this rich environment,
it doesn't really make
much sense
to use HTML as our--
as our data format.
So--so we want to be able
to define
our own abstract data model.
And that's what we've done.
And so the editor needs
to, uh, be able to map
between that
and the display format,
which is HTML,
because you're in a browser.
Uh, at the same--
and furthermore,
we want to have full control
over what's going on.
We don't want to be
at the mercy of the browser.
We want
to, uh, define exactly
what the interactive
experience is like.
And international, uh, support
is also, uh, a top priority.
So we want to be able
to support RTL,
Input Method Editors,
so and so forth.
So how do we do all that?
Okay. Firstly,
um, our document model
that we happen to choose,
uh, is XML plus annotations.
So XML we use
for the structured,
uh, for the structure
of our document,
and then we annotate regions
of that XML,
uh, with annotations.
So here's a simple example.
I'll talk a bit more
about annotations in a sec.
Um, but, uh, here's a simple
example of that.
So we have--uh, in the demo,
you probably saw
a whole bunch of images
being uploaded into a Wave.
So here's an example
of that.
And as you can see here,
it's very simple.
It's just a w:image--
just a namespace
we're arbitrarily using
at the moment--
and an attachment
and the caption.
So that's nice
and straightforward.
And the HTML for that
is, you know, all this junk.
So you don't want to be having
that in your data model.
Annotations, as I mentioned,
uh, they're simply,
basically, key-value pairs
over regions of the document.
Uh, each item conceptually--
an item in the document
is a start tag, a character,
and an end tag.
Each--each item
conceptually has a map
of key-value pairs.
But if they're adjacent
and contiguous,
you can think of them
as ranges.
So we have some styled
red text
overlapping with link.
So, um, nice properties
of these annotations
as you can see
is that they can overlap
and they don't contribute
to the size of the content.
So if we had to put
all these <bold> </bold>
and <link> </link> tags
in there,
um, firstly,
they don't overlap nicely.
We'd have to split them up.
And it sort of pollutes our--
the--the clean structure
of the XML.
So clients can ignore
the annotations
they're not interested in.
If you're not interested
in spelling annotations,
for example,
you just don't render them.
If you are, you do.
Um, yeah, so uses,
uh, if--if you saw those carets
and--and highlighting
of other people's selections,
we just use annotations
for that.
Uh, yeah, rich links.
Robot-specific data.
So, for example, if a metadata
doesn't have to be rendered,
it's up to, uh, the client
or the--the robot
to interpret this stuff.
Uh, diff highlighting
as well.
Uh, and also the value
in the annotation.
You could by convention
have that reference
some other structured piece
of data
and another document
to store more information.
Okay, so how do we actually
render this stuff,
um, from XML to HTML?
XSLT anyone?
Ha ha ha ha.
Uh, well,
so we don't do that.
Um, we...
[laughter]
We--we maintain
a-a-a nice mapping
from--so we have a--
we have our DOM,
which is our XML model
over here.
And in the browser,
we have an actual tight mapping
to the corresponding
HTML rendering here.
Uh, so this is act--
an actual object reference.
So by default, where--
where our model is the same--
so P for paragraph,
and text nodes,
and so and so on--
when that--
when that matches HTML,
it's very efficient.
Uh, when you want
to append a child to the XML,
we just get the corresponding
HTML node appended
to the corresponding place
in the DOM.
So that happens
very quickly.
But if you want
to do something fancier,
of course,
you can do that as well.
So, uh, with the image
thumbnail example,
again, we have this image
corresponding to a div
and some very complicated stuff
in here.
And that attribute here
maps to--to this source
attributing the image.
So you can define any custom,
uh, rendering
that you--that you wish,
okay?
And so now a bit
about annotations.
So--so we have that content
and we want
to annotate it thusly.
We have,
uh, a spelling error here.
We have a link.
Uh, some styled text
with overlapping styles.
See how he--
we just annotate them
and the annotations overlap
quite nicely.
And we want it to render
like this.
And I just want to emphasize
the fact that we want
to render it like this
is merely the choice
of our particular client.
You can render it or interpret
this information
however you want.
Uh, so the way
we actually do that,
um, is we just have a little--
in our editor,
we have a little utility
that goes through
and does the actual--
renders those annotations
into additional XML,
which is only stored locally.
It's not sent to the server.
And this does
all the resolution
of the overlapping
annotations.
So as you can see here,
we've got bold,
bold and italic,
and just italic.
Uh, and there's an extra node
here to--to control
this little drop down
that we--we want.
And then to render that
to HTML,
we do that thing
I showed earlier,
um, where we have a nice,
uh, usually one-to-one,
but it--often,
arbitrary mapping.
Okay, so quick summary.
Um, from document to HTML DOM,
we have the fast path for--
which is be--beneficial
for when you're just pressing
enter a lot, or typing,
or backspacing.
But--and then also,
uh, you can set up your own
mutation handling
and custom rendering.
And this stuff can also be used,
uh, for server-side rendering,
so on and so forth,
not just the editor.
Okay, so, now, the other side
of the coin
is extracting operations.
So how do we do this?
Um, well, step one
is you...
make yourself
a little test harness.
Uh, and you go, uh--
so that's the events I got.
Okay. So I get that.
And then I did a key there.
And then
the DOM actually changed.
Um, and then let's say
I want to type in Chinese.
And I go, oh, that's nice,
browser changed with DOM first
and then gave me
a-a key event.
How handy.
Um, so anyway,
so you--you figure
all this stuff out first,
and then--and then you, um,
you--you decide,
okay, some of these things,
uh, the browser does nicely.
Others it--
it doesn't deal well.
So, for example, bullet points
are a notorious example.
Um, some things
we can't handle.
Like IME input.
Uh, if--if you get
a key event,
it's not going to tell you
what the user's doing.
So what we do is we--we try
to strike a balance
between, uh,
allowing the browser
to do its thing
in a contentEditable region
and, um, handling events
ourselves.
So, um, here's
a quick summary.
So here's the browser
doing things.
We get events, usually.
Sometimes does
arbitrary things.
Uh, and, uh, our event router
decides to funnel stuff off
to handlers
or to notify extractors--
I'm just moving
very quickly here--
sorry, um, which--
which will inspect the HTML
and then update our model
accordingly.
If--if, uh, it goes
to a handler,
we just update
the document directly,
which then reflects
the change in the HTML.
So, for example, I'll give you
a little demo here
to hopefully illustrate this
a bit better.
Um, this is--
this is a little demonstration
of two editors here.
So I've got one on one side
and one on the other.
So I just type in.
Stuff appears.
You can see, we have a P here
and a P there.
And this extra BR
is just needed for Firefox to--
it's just the way
it needs it.
So if it's just the HTML,
we don't have to keep that
in our--in our content.
Um, and so--
so as you can see,
uh, down here,
we have notifying extractor,
and then we--we--we get
an operation from that.
Whereas if I press enter,
um, you can see here,
we prevented
that--that event.
We didn't want
the, uh, the browser
to do that because it's going
to munge up the--the DOM.
So instead, we handle that
ourselves programmatically.
Um, yeah,
so that's a rough overview.
So that's,
um, just a summary there.
Um, and do I--yeah.
So--so in summary,
what we do,
um, we--we've got an editor
that allows an arbitrary mapping
from, uh, some document model
that we choose to HTML
and--and, uh, fine-grained
extraction of operations.
And we leverage the browser
where possible for layout
or for IME support,
for example.
But--but for other things,
uh, where possible,
where the browser doesn't do
exactly what we want,
we--we simply handle that
programmatically ourselves.
So hopefully, uh, that gives you
a quick overview.
And now
I'll introduce Casey,
who will talk
about all the cool things
you can do with--with all this
when you put it all together.
[applause]
Whitelaw: Thanks, Dan.
So, uh, I'm Casey.
I work on the Natural Language
Processing Team
for--for Walkabout--
for, uh, Wave.
We, uh, we had
a Natural Language
Processing Team
from really early on.
And I think
that's really interesting.
That's something I'll talk
about a little bit.
Um, I'm in the enviable position
of having all of the hard work
done for me already.
Um, these guys
have given me a system
that, uh, has already got,
uh, you know,
uh, concurrency control,
live editing,
and an incredible editor
to show this in.
Um, so today,
I'm going to talk,
uh, mostly about--
about spelling,
which hopefully
was on the demo this morning.
But I also want
to use that as an example
of how you can build
smarter tools on top of Wave.
Um, this is the thing
that I'm personally
most excited about.
So I want you
to keep this in mind
while I'm talking
about spelling
that this is not something
that's spelling specific.
So the properties
of Wave that--
So I really think
that--that Wave
is an incredible platform
for building smarter tools.
Um, and the reason for this,
first and foremost,
is structure.
So like we've been
talking about,
Wave's XML with annotations
on top of them.
Um, this lets you represent
the information
that you want to put
in a Wave explicitly, right?
So we're not storing
munged up HTML.
We're not storing
plain text.
You can put the content
that you want--
it's XML,
so it's extensible--
right there in the Wave
and then you can collaborate
on it.
That's the second one.
Collaboration.
Um, collaboration
doesn't just involve people.
It involves robots too
as Dan told you
in the API talk
and--and I'll get to
as well.
And it's live, right?
So you can be doing this
in exactly the same data
at the same time.
And last of all
is the fact
that 'cause Waves are hosted
and robots can live
in the cloud,
you can do
some really exciting things.
Um, so spelling,
if this goes well
and I've got the network,
I'm going
to give you a brief demo.
Oh, dear.
Um, just a second.
I'll just log in.
Uh, Dan,
I'm typing Chinese.
[laughter]
It's all right.
I got it.
Um, that Euro didn't exist.
I don't know why.
Okay, I'll just be a second.
So, uh, uh, Lars got to do
all the--the cute demos
this morning
with, uh, Iceland and so on.
But, uh, I'm going to see
if I can just,
uh, turn up the screen size
so you can see it.
And...okay.
All right.
Maybe a little bit too big.
Smaller. Smaller.
Something like that.
All right.
So actually having this
not on my screen
is going to make this
a perfect demo.
Um, usually what I do
is just kind of type
for awhile
and see what happens.
Uh, right.
I scrolled off to the right.
So you can see here,
we've got, uh, spelling
corrections coming in here.
Jinda?
Yeah, nothing good there.
Um, so, uh, let me see
if I can make my--
let me see if I can just,
uh, get this--
That's better.
Um, okay.
So how's everyone going
out there?
Right. So you saw--
oh, dear--
um, you saw a bad example
of autocorrection
doubling up a word.
How's everyone going
out there?
It's pretty nerve-racking
on stage here.
And...
All right.
So maybe I'll go back
to the canned demos then,
uh, you know.
Uh, so, uh, let me--
let me give this one more shot.
Um, let me give this
one more shot.
All right.
So everything apart
from that little thing--
it's going on right there--
uh, you can--you can see
the intention here.
So what we're doing
with spelling--
um, doesn't always do this.
Uh, what we're doing
with the spelling,
uh, is, uh, trying to--
trying to, uh, do a better job
of spelling in context
so that you don't have
to, uh, slow down
and you can just keep on
typing.
Um, the--the reason behind this
is, you know, with Wave,
we're really trying
to increase your productivity.
In the same way that we transmit
your keystrokes straight away,
we figure
that if you can just relax
and type 5% faster,
that's 5% less time
that you spend typing
and it's 5% more time
you can spend
doing something else.
Um, so, uh, you know,
uh, not only do we want
to be able to recognize
your spell--spelling mistakes
more accurately,
um, when we're confident,
we'll actually try
and autocorrect them as well.
Um, so, uh,
how do we do that?
Uh, that was--right.
So the--the--the pieces
of this puzzle,
um, first you're going
to need some way
for, uh, spelling suggestions
to interact with the user,
um, and that's what
we've got here.
So you saw the dropdown.
You saw the autocorrection
that--that misfired slightly.
Um, so here, you know,
is a quick example
of a word
that's been flagged
and a set of suggestions.
And they are--
each of those suggestions
is more or less likely.
Um, and then, so, you know,
this is the kind of thing
you want to see
in the client.
And Dan told you
how we can extend our client
on the editor.
And then you need some way of
representing it.
So I said it's just XML.
So, you know, represent it
exactly the way
that--that you want to.
Get a spell tag in there
with suggestions
and then use this
as an annotation
for the range.
You know, there's a set
of suggestions here.
They're the words
and the--the scores
that, you know, we think,
uh, which ones are how likely.
So this is
straightforward, right?
You know, there's--
there's nothing particular--
it's exactly just representing
the problem
that we're trying to represent
in the Wave.
Um, and then there's
the third bit.
So this is a little bit
trickier than the first two.
We're going to make Spelly,
the spelling robot.
So, uh, so Spelly
is an agent--
uh, the same as the ones
that you can build on App Engine
except we have built it
inside Google Data Centers--
um, that is a participant
on your Wave,
um, and can see changes
as they arrive--
as--as they happen
on the Wave,
um, check your spelling,
and then make suggestions
by--all it does is write
those suggestions
back into the Wave.
Um, uh, so here's a--
here's a example.
I'll walk through this
from end to end
just so you can see
what's going on.
Um, so here's an example,
uh, with a-a Wave.
I said, you know, uh, "let's
meet for lunch tomorrow."
Um, and in the split,
I've written,
"Let's meet tomorrow morning,"
although
I misspelled "meet."
I spelled it M-E-T here.
Um, so imagine
that I just typed this,
um, you know, and it's being
live transmitted.
Um, so what
actually happens is,
uh, as, uh, David and Alex
told you,
um, we bundle these changes up
into operations
and we merge these
and send them to the--
to the server.
So let's imagine that the delta
that we've got right now
is just the--this chunk
of letters
from--from the E of "met"
through to, you--you know,
the O of "morning,"
right?
So, you know, we--we're batching
these up,
we're sending them.
Um, one of the key things
about Wave
is efficiency
and scalability.
So I'll mention this
a few times here.
We're not--we're not sending
the entire text around.
We're not sending things,
necessarily,
character by character.
You know, we're sending
these deltas through.
Or the--the delta
gets sent back
to the Google Wave service.
And the delta--
either the same one
or a transformed delta--
then gets passed on to Spelly.
So Spelly already has some--
some pre-existing Wave state
that it has.
And it just has to apply
that transformed delta
so that it now has
the up-to-date Wave state.
So again, it's just sending
a delta.
This is not
a special connection.
This is, you know,
exactly the same connection
that any client would use
with the Google Wave service
as well.
Um, so then--
so Spelly gets it and knows
where these changes
have happened in the document.
And because
it's interested in words,
it's going
to tokenize it now.
So I've highlighted in yellow
the area that it's changed here.
The--the same thing happens
for every word
that we're interested
in spell checking.
So let's just concentrating
on the interesting word here,
which is "met."
Um, so for the word "met,"
uh, let's say that we don't know
anything about language,
um, and we don't know
which words
are well spelled
or misspelled.
That's exactly the situation
that Spelly's in.
It doesn't have
a single dictionary in it.
There's no hard-coded
information at all.
It's a completely
statistical system
that we learned
from the web.
So the first part
of that is an error model,
which is a context-free model.
Given any word, um, it--
let's assume that that word
is misspelled
and let's find other words
that are likely corrections
for this word.
So, of course,
likely corrections
are things that are going
to be relatively close
in edit distance space,
you know,
depending on how you define
edit distance.
Um, and so there are going
to be things
like the word "meat,"
the food, you know,
which you would get--
if you accidentally left
an A off, you would get "met."
And "meet," which is the one
we're interested in--M-E-E-T.
You know, and "net"
and "get" and "me."
You know,
there's all these words,
that you could have meant
when you actually typed "met."
Um, so the likelihood
of these various misspellings
and so on, as I said,
this is a context-free
error model.
We're just considering
the word "met"
and nothing else.
But we get a-a list of these
and their likelihoods.
Second, for each
of these candidates,
we evaluate them
in the context.
So this is, you know,
part of the magic
that we can do with Spelly.
Um, so we look
at the context here.
I'm just using a single word
of context on either side
to illustrate this.
Um, and you--
you look at how likely
each of these phrases are.
So "let's met tomorrow,"
uh, doesn't sound so good.
"Let's meat tomorrow."
Well, maybe if you're going
to a barbecue.
Um, "let's meet tomorrow."
That sounds better.
"Let's net, let's get,"
and so on, you know.
So as you can see,
the combination
of this--the error model
and the language model
together
gives us enough information
to work out how likely
each of these is,
um, as the original--
as a--as the intended word.
Um, so just a note
about the language models here.
These language models
are really big.
So they're the same kinds
of things that we use
for the Rosetta machine
translation service,
um, which is what you saw
in Rosy in the demo as well.
Um, and we literally,
you know,
train these from the web
from all the data
that we can get
our hands on.
Billions of web pages,
billions of words
turned into
multi-multigigabyte models.
Um, these are not the kind
of things
that you can run
on your desktop
and they're certainly not
the kind of things
that you can run
on your mobile phone.
Um, so it's lucky
that somebody else
is doing that for you.
It actually works out
pretty cheap
on a per user basis
because they're--
they're large share models
that everyone can use
together.
Um, okay, so, uh,
so language models.
We get to pick the word.
So we've--we've chosen
that "meet" with two Es
is correct.
And all that Spelly has to do
is send back to the,
uh, to the server,
uh, a-a new delta,
which says annotate
the original word "met"
with this, you know,
piece of XML
that says this is
a spelling mistake
and these are the suggestions
that I've got for it.
And these are how likely
they all are.
Um, and that's it.
So it just sends it back.
And that gets propagated out
to all the rest of the clients
just like any other change.
So spelling works
really, uh, quite well
in--in Google Wave.
Um, this isn't just
coincidence.
Um, like I said, you know,
we started looking
at natural language applications
early on--early on in Wave.
Um, and you might think--
so, uh, uh, the--the liveness
of--of Wave,
you know, is great
when you can see
multiple people
editing nearby each other.
And it's actually very useful
in practice.
But the, uh,
you might think
that the lengths
that we've gone to
with our concurrency control
are not really
all that necessary
'cause how often
are you actually,
you know, kind of styling
somebody else's text
at the same time?
We always wanted
to be able to do
this kind of thing.
We always wanted to be able
to do server-side spelling
and then a whole lot
of other rich,
smart applications
on top of Wave.
Um, and so when we started,
we're like,
"Oh, well, if we want
to do that,
"then we're going
to have to build in some way
"of, you know, like, letting
this special spelling service
get in there and, like, make
these really tight changes."
And it turns out, you know,
you get it all for free
if you just--like, if you're
going to do that for spelling,
then you can do it
for everything, right?
Or if you're going to do it
for people,
you get to do it
for spelling for free, right?
So this one system supports
exactly the kind of things
that--that you need to be able
to support this kind
of--of system.
Again, with the XML as well,
if we hadn't gone down
that rich structured path,
um, doing this kind
of thing
would've been much more
difficult.
Uh, so I just wanted
to talk a little bit
about, you know,
why it's different
to solve this problem
in this way.
So the--the biggest thing,
like I said,
uh, so you--you can get
the same quality spell checking
from any device that you're
accessing Google Wave from.
So if you're accessing it
on your mobile device
or on your desktop
or on your laptop,
you get access
to exactly the same Spelly
as ever--as everywhere else.
And this is
really powerful, right,
'cause there's no way,
you know, even if we can pack
some kind of language model
into your, you know,
into your Android,
we can't do that
for 40 languages,
or, you know,
100 languages,
but we can do that
in a Data Center.
So that's a huge advantage.
Um, we can, again, uh,
get better quality
by using more data.
And I think this is the way
that statistical natural
language processing
is moving in general.
We're just saying
that the more data
that you use--you know,
if Peter Norvig was here,
he would, uh, accuse me
of stealing his lines.
But, you know,
the more data that you use,
the easier it is to solve
these--to solve these problems
and you see improvements
in quality.
Um, like I said,
so we can share the resources
as we--when we put
these, uh, smart services
in the cloud.
We can share the relatively
expensive resources
between many users who are all
using the same system,
um, which makes it feasible
to do this in the first place.
Um, one thing
I didn't mention
when I was going through the--
the Spelly demo just before,
the walkthrough--
is you'll notice
that we are only--
we know exactly where
the changes happen in the text,
which means we don't have
to respell the entire document,
right?
So, you know, this is
another efficiency thing.
We're not shipping
whole documents around.
We're not reannotating
entire documents the whole time.
Right?
If you--if you look
at the--the system naively,
you'll think there is no way
that you can possibly
scale this.
There's no way that you can
possibly do this
for millions of documents,
you know,
for millions of people
all the time.
And--and--and so
we didn't do the naive thing.
Just--just in case
you were wondering.
Um, one other thing
about robots here, you know,
as--as a way of implementing
services like spelling,
uh, is that
they're interactive.
So not only can Spelly
write into the Wave,
but it's continuing to interact
with you on the Wave.
So it can see
what you do later on.
So, for instance, if it flags
a word as a misspelling,
uh, and then you, uh,
accept its correction,
then that's positive feedback
that you've done
the right thing.
You know,
congratulations.
If you autocorrect something
and then they go back
and they, uh, say, "Actually,
no, that wasn't what I meant,
I meant something else,"
that's really strong negative,
uh, negative, uh, signal
that you've done
the wrong thing
and you should probably
never do that again.
Um, so, that's not
what you're seeing
at the moment in Spelly,
but that's something
that we can certainly do.
And that's something that you
generally can't do
with these kind of systems.
Uh, okay, so I--
like I said,
this is about
more than, uh, spelling.
It's about a whole range
of other applications,
uh, that you can think of
and I can think of.
And, you know, if you've got
a background in this stuff,
you're already thinking
of 100 things that you can do,
if you're anything like me.
Uh, so, an interesting thing
about Wave
is also that it provides
a platform
for collaboration
between robots.
So forget about people
for a second.
Um, you know, you can get
a language identification robot,
working together
with spellchecker
so you know
which language model to use.
Um, you can bring,
uh, Rosy the translator in
so that it uses
the language ID.
And if there's
a spelling mistake,
it can, you know, consider
the spelling mistakes as well
when it's doing
a translation.
You know, all of these things
can interact.
You know,
if you can identify names
in the text,
then you might know
that when you're
translating names,
for instance,
you can treat names specially.
You know, you can use
transliteration
instead of trying to do
normal--normal work.
And you can do this,
you know, in a traditional,
kind of multi-agent system
kind of a way
by making specialist agents
which are all good
at what they do.
And, remember, these don't
all have to be written
by the same person,
right?
They're just collaborating
in one Wave.
Uh, and they can all work
together.
Uh, the most important thing
in this though,
uh, I think, you know, that many
multi-agent systems lack
is that there are users
in this system
doing live interaction
as well.
And the purpose
of all these,
you know,
of all these agents,
the robots,
um, is that they're there
to help you be more productive
and get your work done.
So it gives a real focus
to the tasks that they're doing,
which I think sometimes
are lacking
in these kinds of systems.
So this is--
this is really exciting.
I-I think that,
uh, this model
of being able to represent
your structure explicitly,
um, being able to, uh,
host services that are smart,
uh, that you can--
that you can use
a large amount of data
to build,
and that you can deploy
to many, many users
and then interact
collaboratively with them,
um, is really powerful.
And I think, you know,
spelling and things like that
are only just the beginning.
That's all I got.
[applause]
So, we've--we've got
13 minutes and 47 seconds
for questions.
Please use the microphones
if you questions
for any of us.
Um, and I would like
to remind you again
to go to www.haveasec.com/io
for feedback about this session.
Um, also feel free
to grab any of us
after the--well, me,
I'm volunteering me.
I'm volunteering
all of these guys as well.
Feel free to grab us
after this
if you can find us and ask
those questions then too.
man: Do you see any down sides
to applying these concepts
of, let's see,
your composition algorithm
and your natural language model
to source code
to kind of replace SVN
and other burgeoning software
to look at diffs
more efficiently?
Whitelaw: Um, well,
I'll take th--
man: I guess, that's,
you know, a two-part question
for both of you guys.
Whitelaw: I'll take
the natural language
and then you guys can take
the--the OT stuff.
Um, so you can use--
so, you know, many people
have had the idea
of using this
to build an ID.
And--and we think
that's fantastic.
And, you know,
if we had a lot of time,
which we don't, we would
probably have built one too.
Um, and so the way
that you could do this
kind of, you know,
smarter assistance
is the same kind of things
that you see in Eclipse
and so on, you know.
They're trying to help you.
But if you can imagine
having, you know,
a data center behind, uh,
Eclipse autosuggest instead,
I think
that's really powerful.
Mah: Okay, um...
what's your question?
Whether you could, uh, use,
uh, the concurrency control
for SV--uh, as a replacement
for search control?
man: A little more efficiently
at the, uh, differences.
Mah: Um, I don't know.
Because the--our--
our algorithms,
um, they never fail, in--
[laughter and applause]
Whitelaw: That's the--
that's the down side.
Mah: Yeah, that--
Because, uh, when you--
when you--
in--in source control,
um, their--
their merge algorithms
are--are designed,
uh, so that, um,
if you--it--
you'll detect conflicts.
And, uh, if there's
any conflicts,
um, you'll--you'll--
you'll have a merge failure
and you have
to resolve it manually.
Um, the--the reason
is because,
uh, these source controls,
uh, they actually emphasize,
um, the actual
document states, okay?
They don't actually emphasize
the changes
between the documents.
Um, so what you--what you do
is, uh, in the search--
source control, um,
um, the--the document states
are the primary objects
and the changes between them
are the secondary.
You generate
the changes between
by looking at the--the, um,
the--the documents states
before and after
and you do some sort of,
uh, diff algorithm.
Uh, but what we--
what we have here
is, uh, our operations
are actually the primary object.
The document states
are only the, um, the result
of performing operations.
Um, all, um,
all our--all our algorithms,
um, our transformations
are on composition.
Um, they're performed,
um, directly on the operations.
Um, so it's impossible
for them to fail
because the operations
are primary objects.
Um...
man: That's great.
That's exciting.
Mah: Yeah. [laughs]
Whitelaw: Uh, someone
from over here.
man: His question sort of,
uh, got ahead of mine.
But I was interested
in terms of especially
in programming languages,
but really in anything
where you have a community
that has their own language.
You know, people in a company
throwing around
their own set of TLAs,
or two doctors
throwing around medical terms,
or two of somebody else
throwing something else around.
How does the, uh, lang--
the natural language cope
with essentially communities
with--with divergent
vocabularies?
Whitelaw: So that's--
that's a really good question.
Um, and there are a couple
of variants on that.
Your people also discuss,
you know,
things like the, uh,
di--regional variance.
You know, uh,
British and American English
and so on.
Um, so I think the--
we have one generous--
and so as I said, we're--
we're learning from the web.
So we're very up-to-date
with the, you know,
the kinds of words
that we know about.
Um, that means that,
you know,
we can correct--
correct LOL Speak quite well.
Um, uh, but it doesn't help us
with, you know,
organizational jargon.
Um, there's the user
personalization
that I talked about
is one avenue
that you can attack that by
where you can do
per user models.
Um, it's not--
but it's not as efficient
as if you could have
a domain-wide,
you know,
corporation-wide model.
Um, and I think that,
you know,
together, the kind of,
uh, Google Apps field
domain model, you know,
where we, uh, already know
about, you know,
the--the organizational
structure and so on
and you know about the--
the domain of accounts,
um, that that's a really
exciting way to do.
So you--if you start--
talking about particular TLAs,
Spelly will stop flagging them
as mistakes for everybody
in the company.
man: Thank you.
man: Uh, yeah,
so one question is,
um, like, to--
uh, whether the sort
of Operational Transform
magic stuff is available
in the form of white papers
or source code
that might be available
to other just random people
trying to do--
Wang: I'm glad you asked
that exact question
because if you go to,
I believe, Waveprotocols.org...
Whitelaw: Yeah, Wave--
Waveprotocol.org.
Wang: Waveprotocol.org,
there's actually white papers
for OT available right now.
And, um, it also has,
um, the actual federation
protocol as well
if you're interested
in working with Wave.
Um, what was
the other question?
I think you had two.
man: Okay, so the other question
sort of relates
to the source code thing,
which is just
the really pragmatic one
of if you're using Wave
and you're sending
source code around,
it's going to start flagging
all kinds of words
as being misspellings.
How do you tell Spelly
to ignore parts
of the document, say?
Whitelaw: Yeah,
so--so I mentioned,
uh, you know,
like a language ID agent
as part of the system
that we have already.
Um, so that's a way
that we can automatically try
and detect those differences.
But we will have, um,
uh, manual overrides
where you can eventually--
essentially flag off
areas of a text and,
you know,
say, "No, Spelly,
don't come in here.
"Don't--don't correct my,
you know,
Is to Js in my, uh,
my folders."
Danilatos: Can I just add
to that?
Um, as I--
as I mentioned earlier,
the--the interpretation
of those annotations
is up to the client.
So you could easily
have your client just ignore
spelling errors,
um, in the document
or in regions of the document
that you choose.
man: Is there any plans
to expose APIs
for things like Polly
so that outside of Wave,
you can use these services
for doing
really intelligent spelling
based on your wonderful Google
data set?
Whitelaw: Um, I'd say,
uh, you know,
we--we love exposing APIs.
I don't have anything
particular to say.
But, um, you know,
obviously,
better spelling
is not something
that we only need in Wave.
You know, there's lots of other
applications for it as well.
man: So, uh,
another major problem
with collaboration
and--and email and identity,
yeah, well, is identity.
And from what I've heard,
the only thing I see
is kind of email-like strings
out there.
You know, phishing is probably
the biggest problem
with email these days.
Uh, you're doing
a federated model here.
I--can you wade,
uh, quite a ways more
into your security vision
on authentication
and how do I know
that Bill Gates
didn't actually write that flame
about, you know, whatever?
Whitelaw: Do you want
to take that, Dave?
Wang: Yeah.
So, um, if you do go
to, um, Waveprotocol.org,
there's a white paper
exactly addressing
this particular question.
Um, so once you federate,
operations that gets exchanged
between service providers
do get signed.
And even if you propagate
the operation
across service providers,
um, you can still verify
it came from a specific source.
So, um, so in a sense,
you--you can--
you're protected in some way
to know who you want to allow
into your system
and who you don't want to allow
in the system.
And it's completely up to you,
the service provider,
to provide the protection
if you want to.
Whitelaw: I should add
that in the--
in the short term
for Wavesandbox.com,
so the--the initial, you know,
release to developers,
accounts will be white listed.
Uh, so you'll add acc--
contacts explicitly.
So, but, yeah,
where--you should
check out a white paper.
man: So example,
is there any registry
of domain names
and which, uh,
federation providers
get to claim
a domain name?
Is it just their own
or, you know?
Whitelaw: Yeah, I think
it's really early--early days.
Wang: I think it's still
very early in the stage.
So, um, best to start off
with white papers.
And there are questions,
um, feel free to email us
and we can work
through that.
Whitelaw: Send us a Wave.
Wang: [laughs]
man: So you've got these
really giant language models
for the spelling thing,
right?
And so, I mean,
for English,
you're just crawling the web
and that's huge.
And maybe for Chinese,
you might get a lot.
Maybe for Korean,
What are the roadblocks
to onboarding,
you know, small,
third world country languages
in places where we're really
trying to get people
onto the internet,
onto all the new technology?
But you're not going to find
eight billion web pages
in [indistinct]?
Right?
You're going to find two.
Whitelaw: So that's a--that's
a really fantastic question.
And I'm really glad
you asked that
because, you know,
the Wave isn't just
for first world countries
where we've already got plenty
of content out there, right?
Um, so to be fair,
I don't think that better
spelling correction
isn't what's keeping
third world countries
off the web.
man: No. Sure.
[laughter and applause]
Whitelaw: So, um, uh,
you know,
what--what I would love
is, uh, so we're using the web
because we don't have
a better understanding so far
of the way that people
actually communicate
with one another.
Um, for whatever communities
start communic--
start communicating
with each other in Wave,
um, we can learn explicitly
from that
rather than from the web
as a whole.
I'd be happy to follow up
with you after this too.
man: Do you provide
the integration possibility
with third party system--
uh, third party
account systems
or would you have to, uh,
roll your own Wave server
in order to, uh,
use third party accounts?
Wang: Um, um, let me--
let me try--
I don't completely understand
the question,
but let me get a stab at it.
You mean third party
email systems like, um...
Whitelaw: I--I've used
everything else on my site
and I-I want to be able
to use Wave
without making my users,
uh, have Google accounts.
Wang: Right.
So, um, so I guess
there's many ways
you can, uh,
solve this problem.
Uh, one problem
is run your own Wave server.
I mean, that's, uh,
a bit hard, I think.
But much easier thing to do
is, perhaps, to go to robot.
Um, if you've been
to Gary's talk previously,
um, I think there's
a very nice API already
for building robots.
I think it's very easy path
to enter into that sort
of messaging service
if you wanted to do that.
Does that answer
your question?
man: Um, so building a robot
can, um--
So--but you don't require
somebody to have an account
in the system
to send a message?
Whitelaw: Sure please.
Wang: Yeah, sure.
Hannon:
'Cause I'm not miked up,
I just thought I'd stand
over here.
Today, I think his question
was about logging in
and whether people required
Google accounts.
Today for this early
developer preview
and probably for a little while,
it is a Google account.
Um, so you--you--
probably a lot of people
in this room
already have Google accounts.
You can use that
to get into Wave.
In the end,
we'd like to integrate
with something
like Friend Connect
and let people use different
authentication systems
to get to Wave.
So we'd like to get there,
but, um, we're not quite
there yet.
Whitelaw: Thanks.
That was our PM.
Uh, yes.
man: Just a simple request.
Is there any chance
of turning on Spelly
for YouTube comments?
[laughter]
[scattered applause]
man: No, seriously,
a question,
uh, about the simple,
uh, features,
uh, that we do have
in email accounts
like, uh, distribution lists
and CC and BCC lines.
And what about,
uh, spam prevention?
Whitelaw: So--so notions
like CC and BCC
don't really apply
directly to the Wave model.
You know, we have
a different kind
of participation model
as you might have heard already
in Dell's talk.
Uh, so we definitely
support groups.
Um, and I hope
that you'll get to see
a lot more about groups
in the future.
We'll--we'll talk
about them more.
You know,
we already have groups
implemented now.
Groups are a really
powerful way
of managing things like
distribution lists and so on.
There's a lot
of groups features
that we're working on.
Uh, again,
this is something--
I think you'll hear
a lot more about this
in the near future.
man: So now you have
only one server for now.
But later, you will allow
people from different servers
to communicate with them?
Wang: That's correct.
So--so it is--we're still
a work in progress.
So with this, uh, federation,
um, process, uh, protocol,
you can actually have
very different servers
that's run by completely
different organizations
that essentially communicate
with each other.
And more--more importantly
with this federation protocol,
information don't get leaked
between organizations
if you don't want them
to be.
man: Your open source
implementation
that at some point
you will release,
will it work on a servlet Tomcat
bare bone or do I have to have--
Wang: Yes. Yes.
So, uh, we--we do plan
to release, um, source code
in some form or another
that will help everyone
get started.
man: On the ser--
on the server side, yes?
Wang:
On the server side, yes.
man: And then I can start it
on my Tomcat
and then--but you--you will have
all your magic there.
Wang: [laughs].
It's going to be magic.
Yes. It's going to be released
in some form.
We're--we--
still work in progress.
We don't know what kind
of form we're releasing,
but eventually
we will release something.
man: Okay. Thanks.
Hannon: Sorry,
I'm going to be interrupting,
like, and just say
that we have office hours
going on still.
So there's a Wave office hour
earlier.
If you want to talk
about federation,
if you want to talk
about the APIs,
it's just out the door
and around the corner.
There's lots of people
from the Wave team there.
And we're really, really
excited to talk to you.
Whitelaw: Um, and that's
a great way to wrap this up.
We're out of time.
So thank you very much.
[applause]